wow welcome back to new rockstars this
is the big question the show that gives
you too much information about the
perfect time to quit your day job move
down to a condo in south florida and
start playing pickleball and
shuffleboard while you collect that
sweet sweet pension retirement baby wait
do we get a retirement here at new
rockstars is that something that we get
absolutely not empty we work until the
day we die
or until marvel stops
my name is mt and i'm here today with
off-screen producer brandon what's going
on brandon hello mt so glad to be here
with you today uh man i can't wait to
retire that's gonna be the best one of
these days
drinking arnold palmer's it's going to
be beautiful my bones feel like they're
at retirement age
i very feel
i'm ready to go my bones are just like
ready to rest out on the beach somewhere
in miami oh there's plenty of bones on
miami
but they didn't get there
the good way they got there the bad way
whoops
rest in peace beach skeleton
[Music]
fun fact i actually can't really walk on
beach surfaces all that well because i
had a surgery on my foot sand be sand we
call that you gotta beat the surfaces if
you're watching surfaces i i don't i
don't leave this room beside i don't
leave the void empty's like an alien
it's his first day on earth he's like
human show me to your beach surfaces
wow is that a beach surface towel
interesting
[Music]
but what is our big question for today
brandon well mt i'm glad you asked the
thor 11 thunder teaser trailer gave us a
look at where thor's headspace is
currently at right and it looks like our
favorite god of thunder is ready to lay
down his axe and give up his day job but
wait can that even happen does there
have to be a god of thunder it all leads
us to this week's big question
can thor just choose to retire the
answer is no
but okay it's interesting question for
sure is life really worth living without
a god of thunder swinging his hammer
around in the clouds more importantly
does the universe need a god of thunder
in order to exist and the best place to
start the discussion is with the
prophecy that means the most to the
asgardians ragnarok ragnarok
so much of the asgardian's existence
appears to be tied to the cyclical
prophecy of ragnarok it's this cycle
which signals death and rebirth for the
asgardians and during the events of
ragnarok many gods die and asgard is
completely destroyed and part of this
prophecy involves thor traditionally as
described in the comics and in real
norse mythology loki and thor will
engage in combat for the last time but
the fight will be interrupted by the
midgard serpent big old snake and thor
ultimately defeats the serpent however
the battle will do significant damage to
asgard it is then that serger will
arrive from muspelheim to finish off
asgard for good then the cycle resets
and begins again so is or the prophecy
of ragnarok
but we've already had ragnarok within
the mcu and it sort of went off book
with thor basically skipping to the end
of ragged rock and within the mcu odin
is completely dead loki is dead and
asgard is destroyed so does this mean
that thor is free to just walk away from
his role as the god of thunder it's a
great point empty because as you said
yeah a lot of these things that are
supposed to happen during ragnarok
happen yeah in a weird way
like odin died but he's supposed to be
eaten by like the fenris right right but
that obviously didn't happen he was dead
before the wolf was brought back to life
and like loki's dead
but he was alive during all of ragnarok
and died like later it wasn't like thor
that killed him yeah another part of
prophecy right is like loki brings the
the giants into asgard which he did do
in thor 2 right so it happened so all
these events kind of happened but they
happened out of order but then yeah
you're right thor just kind of skipped
to the end he was like put the crown on
the internal flame and surter will come
and destroy everything
boom bing bang boom done and it was
interesting right because like ragnarok
was it was a prophecy that existed in
the mcu but they didn't like talk about
it a lot right yeah it just kind of got
brought up at the end right when it is
this like important thing that all the
asgardians live by it's like very
important to their culture like this
like death and rebirth all these things
have happened right right mt but
nothing's been reborn yet like odin's
not back
loki didn't come back there's a new king
of asgard who's valkyrie it is kind of
weird like can he just walk away don't
you have to have a god of thunder and we
do know from thanos in infinity war that
he said no resurrections this time was
so different about their deaths at the
hands of thanos that would you know
warrant them and not ever coming back
and if that can happen then like if we
can't have all these other gods and like
technically maybe thor is as disposable
as them that's a great point empty i
don't even think about this so you just
said it just now like what made thanos
declaration so important did he know
that like he's like i'm gonna do this
i'm gonna kill loki i'm gonna do the
snap and my snap is gonna like change
all the prophecies like it's gonna end
all of that bs interesting because like
did he know like i'm gonna do the snap
and i'm gonna destroy the stones you
think that was always his plan to
destroy the stones i think so because
like if if he knew how powerful and
god-like these stones were going to make
him he he already knew of the temptation
that was going to happen after so like
i'm sure it was always the plan to
destroy the stones because he had no
purpose for them like you said so maybe
the prophecy is like tied to the
infinity stone somehow and he knew if i
if i do the snap and i destroy the
stones even though they still exist in
atomized form blah blah blah blah
if if they're gone gone if those
physical stones are gone then that'll
destroy like all of these like cyclical
prophecies it's not just ragnarok right
mt it's like everything in the universe
is cyclic right that's the whole point
of like he who remains right is to be
there at the end to help start the
beginning of the next year so it's like
thanos maybe was just trying to you know
to quote game of thrones like break the
wheel he wanted to stop this whole cycle
and he knew that like yeah i'll kill
loki and i'm going to do the snap and
i'm going to destroy the stones so
there'll be no more prophecy so now that
the stones are destroyed maybe that
explains why the cycle hasn't reset yet
right that is really interesting to
think about especially if you think
about the nature of the rainbow bridge
and the bifrost and how it's all the
different colors of like the infinity
stones essentially so if the infinity
stones are gone maybe it means that like
the juice that runs asgard can't be like
you know reinstated ah okay that's
really interesting i like that right
right
that's fun i think it look at us just
coming up with great theories right here
live right on the fly we're doing it
it's happening in real time
and maybe that's why like thor is kind
of like i don't want to say he's
depressed but maybe he's he's definitely
depressed feels it inside of him
well he's alone frigg is gone odin's
gone loki's gone jane broke up with him
uh valkyrie who's like a great friend
she's busy she's running asgard and he
doesn't want to deal with it
and yet maybe he thought like his dad
would show up again by now he's like oh
dad's back right
but he has to die too i mean that's part
of ragnarok is like thor dying and like
getting reborn again later
so i don't know maybe he doesn't want to
die just wants to retire thor might be
thinking like maybe my people can't come
back because i'm not dead
like maybe
and i don't want to die that would be so
crazy it's like like i feel guilty for
being alive because i'm the last person
that is like
here to re like bring everyone back to
life so like okay like i don't want to
like get rid of like my life cycle
because then that will like maybe
generate a new variant of thor that's
not him that has different memories it's
kind of like doctor who it's like all
right i'm dying right and i'm getting a
new body but like
uh it's not me but it is me but like
it's just well and maybe he thinks
if the idea of like the god of thunder
dies
not thor physically but like the god of
thunder if i kill the god of thunder if
i say i'm walking away he's dead maybe
that's the last thing that needs to
happen for it all to restart but then he
can stay alive he's just not the god of
thunder he's just thor odinson walking
around
being lonely
let's move on to another point here
because uh the mcu technically has been
thoroughless before because the mcu has
already displayed how there can be a
vacancy in the thor position and part of
the narrative the first thor film rests
on thor being stripped of his title and
being sent to midgard also known as
earth so he can learn what it means to
be a god or you know a less dickish god
because that dude was the worst
i mean a good blonde eyebrows will do
that to you make you a real jerk
oh baby yeah don't dye your eyebrows
don't do that ever again
but yeah this was all done under the
watchful eye of odin so i mean when he
wasn't sleeping anyway good point like
they keeping professor xavier ring odin
every time it's like too powerful time
for a nap i need a nap
and this was all done to make thor a
more responsible leader so what do you
think brandon we have seen like the
vacancy to the god of thunder but it was
like odin was still
around ish and frigga was there watching
and it's like he was still an ass
guardian right but he's just been
stripped of his like thor god of thunder
powers oda knew this was only going to
be like a week right he's a smart guy
he's like he'll figure this out pretty
quick uh and i guess in theory he could
have if it took longer than a week he
could have appointed somebody else as
thor just like fill in the time but it
it does show that like you don't need
the spot 100 filled all the time right
like there can be a lapse of a god of
thunder for a little bit it's okay yeah
because there is a time
when like thor's still a kid right and
he's not the god of thunder and that i
don't
i don't know if there is like a god of
thunder like when boar's around right
yeah say you have bore and you have odin
as like a little boy was odin the god of
thunder before he became the all father
i don't know i might be i think that um
completely wrong i have this weird
feeling that there was no god of thunder
before thor was born and that the actual
like thor is the god of faith that's his
whole role yeah his whole thing is that
he he generates thunder which is why he
didn't need mjolnir to to to be that
powerful and for ragnarok it's like i am
the power i am thor it's inside of him
it's just a way to direct his exact
right using the musing and like in the
comics like there's a huge point where
like thor growing up he's like i might i
want this hammer like i want to one day
be able to lift this hammer and he even
talks to the hammers like i'm gonna lift
you up you stubborn piece of stupid rock
and you're going to be mine and so like
i think that uh yeah like it that that
whole point there was no god of thunder
so like there's definitely a point yeah
where you don't really need one and like
the hammer he loses the hammer oh yeah
he puts it down cap cap has it for a
while loki has it for a little bit it
breaks a bunch he uses something else
for a while it happens he doesn't always
have to drink i've got to be sold
brandon you got to sell them actually we
gotta sell them seriously there would be
no storm breaker if it wasn't action
figures i'm telling you man
god well what about kids i mean i mean
what about them they're terrible
screw them kids them kids uh but anyway
what about kids cathor have some heirs
to pass along the title of the god of
thunder to there have been some
precedent in the comics of thor having
children after all and a lot of
different universes have shown thor
having children especially a thor living
far in the future or way back in the
past but even the main earth 616 showed
thor having offspring because in thor
number 293 from the 1980s they get into
the story of the cycle of ragnarok and
it is revealed that before the most
recent ragnarok a couple of thousand
years ago thor had two sons magni and
modi and these sons wound up sacrificing
themselves to help odin be reborn and
thus all of asgard was reborn including
four and this reborn thor would be the
thor that the 616 universes knows suns
any kids so that's kind of weird and
another infamous incident that involved
thor's offspring happened in the
ultimate universe earth 1610. and in
that universe thor wound up having a son
with the goddess of death hella which
would be kind of weird in this universe
but game of thrones exist i don't think
they were siblings and ultimates i don't
i don't yeah they're not yeah it's yeah
it's a different universe so like
there's different she's she was the god
of the goddess of death she ruled
valhalla it was a little different it
was a little different and like honestly
at the end of the day it's mythology so
they'd be doing that all the time
i mean don't yeah don't get into
mythology yeah i'm like incest is uh all
around the mythology it is the main
name of the game so thor wound up having
a son with the goddess of hella death
who was named modi thorson and thor
winds up leaving him in valhalla and
doesn't raise him and instead he gets
his life's lessons from loki and he
turns out to be a villain who knew and
in the end thor has to kill modi to
prevent him from taking over the world
which is you know classic
classic behavior
i mean that's that's classic parenting
that thor learned right from his dad hey
got a problem with your kid better kill
him better kill your kid hey but so does
thor need to have an offspring to pass
his roll off to before he can just quit
being thor i mean i don't think so but
it is a good point right you would think
like well if i'm not gonna be thor
anymore someone or i'm not going to be
the god of thunder someone else needs to
do it and it is interesting because like
there is all these instances of kids
children of like thor
so you would think at some point he's
got to have kids
uh and yeah the the point you made about
earth 616 right the the previous
cycle thor had these kids that like
sacrificed themselves to bring back odin
and all this crazy stuff but like he
doesn't get around to having them again
in like this version of ragnarok so it's
like come on what are you doing buddy
but i don't think he needs the kids but
this would be an interesting way to pass
on the the mantle right
is if like thor somehow i mean that's
something i would love to see is like as
thor ages
like as chris hemsworth ages marvel goes
on for like another 20 years if he
becomes odin like that would be i would
love that to be the case and like i have
this i have this weird like like
head canon theory that odin used to be a
thor in that like there's like every
thor eventually becomes like
and like they like yeah they become
their father yeah and like they they
have knowledge of the previous cycle but
like they don't really talk about it and
so like they're just the odin of the
next house i would love that to be the
case the comics have shown that like
thor has all the power of like the all
father right but they haven't really
gotten to that in the mcu but again
that's like a really cool idea that as
he
passed if he passes on this mantle of
the god of thunder i would love for him
to become
uh odin now still keep valkyrie as king
valkyrie i'm loving that yeah i don't
want to take that away from her i love
that but yeah odin like taking on the
off all father's power and maybe not
ruling asgard but just being out there
being a god in space celestials you want
to try some [ __ ] let's go
i'm protecting everybody it's not just
about asgardians i'm protecting all the
realms valkyrie's taking care of asgard
but i'm out here i'm i'm thor odin thor
like yeah that would be awesome i mean i
mean like the the the actual job of odin
and like in the previous in all
universes is just to protect the nine
realms this is why i think that he links
up with the guardians in thor four it's
like hey you guys are guardian guarding
the galaxy that's my entire deal let's
link up
that's my whole thing yeah i could
totally see thor just being like this
odin that's like more active than his
more like traditional like all right i'm
just gonna chill around in azeroth
because like that's valkyrie can do that
that's that's the real king's job for
sure in the comics thor has faced a
couple of forms of retirement because
there is the gore of the god butcher
storyline that thor love and thunder
seems to be heavily based on and we know
in that story nick fury tells thor that
gore was right and poof he becomes
unworthy again and walks away from his
hammer so and that's when jane foster
comes in and he also retired from the
avengers because when he became king
thor in 2019 he officially retired from
the avengers and took over ruling asgard
but in the mcu asgard has a ruler in
king valkyrie and it looks like for now
the avengers are pretty much done so
does that mean that thor is really free
to retire
we're gonna get this jane foster
storyline but i don't know if she's
gonna keep the mantle
past this film i think it would be very
interesting if she does it'd be like a
really interesting way to go about it
and like as we were just saying right i
love this idea of thor being like more
like an odin figure and let someone else
be the god of thunder for a little while
or goddess of thunder if you will but
yeah it does seem like there's nothing
tying
thor to this
i won't say realm anymore like there's
certainly nothing tying thor to earth
right that's why he left he's like i'm
good
you're you guys got this under control
and yeah the avengers i don't think are
going to come back in any
i think the next version of the avengers
is going to be like totally new lineup
maybe still have hulk but other i think
mostly a new lineup like if they're not
going to call it a young adventures
that's what it is right it's going to be
the next generation that becomes the
avengers so yeah i really do think like
thor is like free to retire
and i maybe his retirement will be the
last part of ragnarok and like he's not
dead but he's like well
you're retired so the cycle starts over
again i mean we do have that shot in the
trailer that is like super reminiscent
to me of um luke skywalker in his death
in um in the last jedi where like you
know he he just sort of just fades away
and like we know from for the dark world
that during a funeral um when odin slams
his little staff she turns into like a
bunch of sparkles and goes into the sky
yeah she like goes into the universe so
like i wonder if like that's what thor
might do is like all right here's my
retirement and like it's me just like
sort of giving up the
giving up the ghost and just being like
all right time to restart yeah i don't
want chris hemsworth to go away just yet
but like it does feel like i don't if
thor's done being the god of thunder and
maybe at the end of this film he won't
he still won't be the god of thunder
he'll be something else entirely a lot
of the promo material for thor four says
one and only four so like by the end of
four four there's going to be one for
like definitively and it's most likely
going to be jane foster right cause i
can't see thor being like oh thank you
jane thank you for making great strides
for women
thanks for the marketing go back to your
desk
it's good for the universe to have a
protector and that's what like the whole
purpose of mjolnir is to just to protect
um people in in in the entire realm yeah
and like we saw from thor ragnarok that
hella used to be the wielder of mjolnir
and she completely abused her power
which is why i think i wouldn't probably
put that enchantment in the first place
like hey there's too much power and this
is supposed to be for to protect people
and not to hurt people which is what my
daughter wants to do yeah so uh yeah i
think there has to be a guardian i think
that's the whole purpose of the hammer
and i think jane foster is the one to do
it it sounds like you think the universe
can't exist without a god of thunder but
it needs a protection yes right exactly
because i think that you know the whole
purpose of asgard is to protect the
realm from dark forces from people that
want to
hurt these beings of light and for that
to happen there has to be a protector
and that's the god of thunder so it
doesn't have to be
thor odinson i agree mt i think i think
thor can retire but someone has got
there's still got to be a protector out
there if the cycle of ragnarok is not
resetting if if a new odin's not coming
in or a new bore or whatever
uh someone's got to do it
so as long as i think thor is still
around protecting everything's gonna be
okay but yeah maybe we're not gonna have
a god of thunder after this we're just
gonna have thor hey we'll see we'll see
i'm i'm really interested to see what's
going on
um i feel like
we only got one trailer and we're just
like well what's going to happen like
well like
we're i mean give us more baby seriously
come on tyco i want to see the jane
foster trailer release the jane foster
cut immediately but you know what's
already released our new latest
obsession shirt inspired by doctor
strange in the multiverse of madness and
as with all of our latest obsession
shirts there's only a limited number
available and once they're gone from our
universe they're gone for good then
you'll be forced to break into another
universe and steal one from your variant
and then that's not gonna end well
you're gonna have to kill your variant
and then a whole gently the one
situation happens it's not pretty spare
you're very into trouble and check out
newrockstarsmerch.com it's a great way
to support the channel literally it
helps us out so much and score some
really awesome merch as well and before
we dive into our bite size questions
next some words from the people that
help us bring big question to you people
like avast avast is actually a global
leader in cyber security for more than
30 years and is trusted by over 435
million users avast empowers you with
digital safety and privacy no matter who
you are where you are or how you connect
a vast new all-in-one solution a vast
one helps you take control of your
safety and privacy online through a
range of features features like firewall
protection that keeps your personal
information secure and prevents attacks
that seek to access your computer and
steal your data they also offer smart
scan a tool that finds and removes
viruses and resolves the most common
privacy and performance issues through
an optimization scan and avast one
offers both free and premium options and
we here at new rockstars like using a
vast one for their award-winning
anti-virus that stops viruses and
malware from harming all of our devices
and thanks again to avast for supporting
big question avast prevents over 1.5
billion attacks every month and with a
vast one you can confidently take
control of your online world without
worrying about viruses phishing attacks
ransomware hacking attempts and other
cyber crimes so learn more about avast
one at avast.com again that's a vast one
at
[Music]
avastt.com all right brandon you ready
for the bite size questions oh am i get
ready for some num nums
speaking of edible things if galactus
can eat planets
can he eat ass
[Music]
how dare you mt here we go
um if galactus can eat planets does that
mean he can also eat celestials and this
is from fray girl on discord thank you
for a girl yes thank you when it comes
to the diet of galactus he's known for
his proclivity and devouring planets but
it's not like he can just munch on any
old planet out there right he's
interested in planets with sentient
light so he can't just munch on any old
space rock he consumes the cosmic energy
of the planet and really he doesn't like
eat the planet like grab it and chew on
it he's got these machines they convert
things to energy sucks out the energy
and usually there's like a husk of a
planet left behind right he's not just
like eating it out right eating it out
right eating it out right eating it out
right eating it
right
um galactus is of course made of pure
energy himself and that energy is known
as the power cosmic
and this power cosmic fuels all of his
abilities galactus is a primordial
entity much like the celestials and the
celestials themselves also have access
to virtually unlimited cosmic energy
that gives them their abilities right
and we don't even know what they look
like because our tiny human brains can't
comprehend it but i bet they all look
like handsome squidward they're all
handsome squidwards uh under that under
those helmets
we we don't really know how much the
celestials need to refuel like galactus
does
but we do know they need the energy from
sentient beings to hatch out of their
planets right so they're very similar in
that way but like galactus gets hungry
very often right
the celestials just kind of run on their
energy but he he needs to refuel a lot
so there have been instances of galactus
going toe-to-toe with a celestial in
fact a recently fed galactus took on
four celestials and was able to hold his
own oh before at once they ganged up on
my damn they're trying to jump they
tried to jump galactus but he had just
eaten and that was their first mistake
you got to catch him when he's hungry
not after about kfc he let your man eat
yeah yeah he was like i have my spinach
[ __ ]
don't be putting him cracking a planet
it's just like a nearby planet full of
like a whole civilization just dying
for a popeye just the the spinach people
just living on this spanish planet
so this all this all happened in uh
fantastic four number 602 back in 2012.
uh so as long as uh galactus has some
cosmic energy in his tumtum he could
defeat a celestial and drain it of its
cosmic energy so yes he can eat a
celestial because that's how he eats
right he drains the energy he did eat
like a celestial in this comic like he
drained all the energy out of it he also
he walked up on to another celestial
grabbed it and like tore it in half
which was badass yeah
it's pretty awesome
so yeah galactus canadian celestials as
long as he's powered up uh he can do it
otherwise i think the celestials could
take him and also like these are just as
we've talked about before on bq a
celestial in our in our universe is just
an avatar of the main one outside of the
multiverse so
you know kill as many as you want you
haven't done the job
you can't really kill them all right
here's another question brandon what
role will bruce campbell play in
multiversal madness and this is from
order through chaos on discord so right
now as we film this we have not seen
multiverse of matches yet but by the
time you at home are watching it
multiverse of madness will be out so
we're gonna make our picks right now
sight unseen and you could tell us if we
were right or not please don't spoil
anything please no spoilers this is a
very special occasion
so having not seen the movie and knowing
you know bruce campbell is of course one
of sam raimi who directed multiverse of
madness one of his favorite actors was
in the evil dead movies and had
appearances in like all of the other
movies that he's made he's had a little
cameo he's on all three of the spider
boys you can check him out there um so i
think you know i think sam's going to
throw him a bone here i think he's going
to give him a good bit part right a lot
of people think he might show up as like
ash from evil dead like going through
the multiverse i don't think that i
think they're gonna give him a hero to
show up as i think we're gonna get a
quick cameo of bruce campbell as
captain america i think we're going to
get a bruce campbell captain oh my god
all right he's like
maybe not great maybe he's like a little
bit lazy or something
i think he'll show up as like a kind of
old man bruce capp captain america
that's that's my my wild pick what about
umt that would be good i would love to
see that i think he'd make a really
great captain america um i personally
would love to see him as the chameleon
all right because like just because he
had all those different roles oh okay
the sam raimi universe i think it'd be
great if like he was just like all right
i'm the chameleon like i'm a man of i
don't know many like i was all those
things i've been going about the
multiverse like changing shapes i don't
know like it'd be fun if just like if
you're just like around i like it i like
it that's just me being weird that's a
good pick thanks buddy you too but now
it is time for our box of scratch which
is always right it never wrong did you
build stuff with a k in a cave with it
what's happening
you better make me a high-tech iron man
suit you gotta build it with a box of
scraps
but brandon i gotta ask you what is what
would be your dream retirement oh oh man
when i when i hang up the old uh jabra
earpods and kick back and it's time to
retire you know i still i'm still going
to want a job
i'm still going to do something to keep
me active i definitely want to be like a
tour guide
or like a park ranger at some like
historical site and like lead tours for
school children and be that annoying old
man who tells you tons of stories and
facts about wherever you are uh like i
visited i've visited fort sumter many
times uh out there outside of charleston
south carolina and like i love going on
that tour cause like the tour guides
there the park rangers they do a great
job of like making you feel like this is
the most epic place you've ever been in
your life it all started right here i
was like that's what i want to do as a
as an old retiree i'll do it for free
you don't got to pay me
i'll i'll do it i just want to be a tour
guide i love that it's like it allows
you to like interact with people and to
like i don't know just keep your keeps
your mind sharp at that age only in the
retirement age yeah i gotta keep this
all
this old mousetrap sharp i think a dream
retirement scenario
hmm
i probably just want to become a comic
book shop owner honestly it seems pretty
chill
um i just like comic books and i like
like i love being inside of a comic book
store like that's my home like whenever
i get stressed out i like to just go
into a comic book store and just like
rummage through dollar bins and just to
see like all the interesting stuff that
has come out throughout the course of
all these decades because like literally
everyone if you haven't gone to a comic
book store in a while go through the
dollar bins and just pick up stuff and
just like read books for a dollar buy a
book for a dollar and read like all this
really dope [ __ ] because like that's how
i learned all this really fun stuff
about marvel and so like i think support
your locals
stop stop getting your comics on amazon
they show up in the mail they're all
dented it's a mess seriously go to your
local comic books they are the reason
why we have jobs so like let's be real
bro so like go over there and like i
would love to do that as a retirement
because like it just seems fun i get to
talk marvel and show all my god
all those annoying future future kids
generation omega whatever they're going
to be called being like
we read hollow comics that are projected
onto our eyeballs and you're like pick
up a book you whip a snapper
get a paper cut like a real nerd trees
went extinct a hundred years ago old man
but that is it for this episode of big
question thanks again to brandon as
always for joining me on this episode
please follow him at grin and barrack on
twitter you can follow me at
mastertainment on twitter if you want to
see me tweet some weird [ __ ] follow new
rockstars here on youtube and all of our
social media platforms and if you have
some big questions of your own ask them
on discord if you're 18 and older click
the link for the new rockstars discord
server in the description box below and
join the conversation and we love you
guys so much for tuning in with us and
we'll see you guys next time goodbye
bye
[Music]
you